what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so after making the video on
answering the question is Superman a
speedster like the flash one of the
things that I wanted to do or at least
one of the things I asked you guys to do
was begin posting questions that you had
down in the comment section and one of
the questions that was asked is can the
flash fly like Superman now like that
Superman video there's gonna be the
short answer and the long answer the
short answer is no there are no members
of the flash family that can stand in
one place look up and then just take off
it doesn't work that way they aren't
able to fly to a degree but different
writers have done this in different ways
the long answer really ties in this
notion of power scaling for those of you
guys who don't know power scaling is
like this concept of trying to fit a
square peg into a round hole right like
it's shuffling up the pieces on a board
in an attempt to make them fit for
example name with a submariner defeated
The Incredible Hulk and Hulk annual back
in 1997 or 93 I can't over which year
The Incredible Hulk defeated gladiator
one of the many versions of Superman
that exists in Marvel Comics using power
scaling I could then say member the
Submariner would defeat gladiator
because he defeated the guy who defeated
gladiator that's nonsense like like name
of the Submariner would get decimated by
gladiator but power scaling is an
attempt to explain that and it's got
merit in some circumstances but again if
I give you a square peg and I give you a
square hole that peg will fit into that
hole every single time but if I give you
a square peg in a round hole you might
be able to just like force it in but if
you cut the square peg into a circle
then you'll be able to get it in and
that's what power scaling does again the
biggest reason why power scaling is an
issue is because it treats characters as
if they're static right like as if they
never change but they do for example The
Incredible Hulk was never able to
breathe underwater until Hulk issue
number 77 in 2005 when he suddenly
developed the ability to breathe
underwater because the writer wanted him
to and that's the major the reason why I
bring this up is because of the nature
of the flash while the flash is not
necessarily able to fly so to speak the
flash can run on air this happened and
the new 52 with the flash issue number
26 and it was like flash out of his
element or flash out of water or
something on those lines I can't
remember but it was basically a scene
where Barry Allen ran on clouds he ran
on air and though the justification the
writer gave to this story was that
when you're high enough in the
atmosphere because it's so cold moisture
is converted to these sort of crystal
particles and the flash can basically
use the Speed Force to make these
crystal particles come together and then
use them as a surface and run on it it's
speed force I don't have to explain
anything just the way the Speed Force
works
I mean it's that's one of the caveats of
the flash like hey how in the world was
a flash able to do that
no no speed force what do you I'm gonna
tell you it's kind of how that that
thing comes together but aside from like
running on air there have been instances
where a flash was legitimately able to
fly but much like that circumstance the
explanation was not very solid so when
you ask the question can the flash fly
like Superman I'm assuming that you're
talking about Barry Allen or Wally West
those are usually the two most popular
versions of the flash that people point
to now there was a point where Bart
Allen the I guess grandson I think it is
a very Allen from like the 31st century
or something like that was actually the
flash for time after the events of
Infinite Crisis it was a story called
the flash fastest man alive and it ran
for 12 issues I think it was and then of
course Wally West came back and then you
know he went back to being the flash
again however there are members of the
flash family who are not Flash's
themselves the character that we're
gonna be referencing in this video is a
guy named Johnny quick now in December
of 1940 the first flash so to speak was
a guy named Jay Garrick he was basically
the first person whose powers were
basically just running super fast on
land the result is that his his stories
took off people absolutely loved it a
guy who was basically faster than
Superman but was confined to the ground
was really intriguing at the time in
September of 1941 DC introduced Johnny
quick now where Jay Garrick gained his
powers from exposure to heavy water he
passed out he woke up in a hospital and
found that he could run at the speed of
sound Johnny quick was not as fast but
Johnny quick or Johnny chambers
depending on what you want to call him
had basically cracked this formula to
give himself super speed and that's the
way his character went for quite some
time from 1941 all the way up to when he
was reintroduced in the mid 1950s even
all the way up to crisis on Infinite
Earths in the post-crisis landscape but
the idea here is that an all-star
squadron number 22 in 1983 Johnny quick
flew and there was no explanation as to
why it was really just like a guess
right like he's basically jumping over
cars and then he just flies in the air
now
as part of a story that involved a
character named ultra-humanite which is
kind of a weird situation but the
explanation given here is that he was
somehow able to use his powers to negate
the effects of gravity and that's it
that's the only explanation we get
because of the fact that DC was crafting
stories in the 1970s and 1980s for the
sole purpose of boosting readership
trying to get people back in and really
just kind of giving characters whatever
powers they wanted to give them to tell
whatever story they wanted to tell the
time the idea of Johnny quick being able
to fly was passed on to his daughter
Jessie quick the problem with this was
that this was super short-lived
two years later DC launched crisis on
Infinite Earths and crisis on Infinite
Earths served the purpose of not only
rebooting the DC landscape but because
of the fact that gwen stacy had died in
1971 and ushered in this era of realism
in comics which is to say making
characters more grounded in the
post-crisis landscape DC took a page
from the Marvel guidebook and then said
okay so now characters powers are gonna
be more reasonable and they're gonna be
more grounded that's the reason why in
1975 I think it was after Mort Weisinger
retired from editing Superman Julius
Schwartz took over he cut Superman's
powers in half he rendered all
Kryptonite a nerd and then kept Superman
confined to earth he was more grounded
he was more reasonable fans hated it
they wanted to see Superman in space
doing off-the-wall Silver Age Superman
crazy stuff so ultimately things went
back to the way they were before but for
the most part the idea of characters
just being there being able to
arbitrarily fly in a forward direction
was gone when it came to members of the
flash family it was really just this
idea that they could use their
SuperSpeed for a variety of different
things like they could create you know
wind tunnels they could run super super
fast and then just lunge forward and go
further than they normally would be able
to go because they were moving so fast
their momentum would literally carry
them in a forward direction that would
create the illusion of flying and so
that was really about it that was really
as realistic and practical as a god
again that runs all the way up to the
new 52 of course this was really most
prominent during Marc Wade's run of the
flash and the reason why I say that is
because again with the concept of
running on air there was a story called
the flash Born to Run and it was
basically Marc Wade's introduction into
the flash mythos which is to say the
first story arc where he took over the
flash line of comics focusing on Wally
West and in this story Wally West
quite literally outruns the universe
like he just runs in space there's no
surface for him to run on he's just
running through space and then arrives
back on earth it defies all normal logic
of the flash because the flash is power
is being able to run a super speed and
he can't really run if you don't have a
surface to run on so again that's why
things get kind of crazy now the
argument presented in that story if I
remember correctly and I'd have to go
back and read it again was that the
universe itself was kind of like a
surface he was running on his own
friction and along those lines but the
idea was that it was basically a story
told just for the purpose of being able
to tell that stories it was kind of
bonkers but hopefully that presents some
kind of a answer to you guys hopefully
it you know gives you what you were
looking for again the short answer is
that no member of the flash family can
stand in one place look up and just
propel themselves in a forward direction
they have to either be running and lunge
themselves in a forward direction or
they just kind of have to you know run
on air because the rider wants them to
kind of a weird thing but with that
being said guys we're gonna go ahead and
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to come as explained and make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the Robin Court if you
guys enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like and yeah I will catch you
all later peace
[Music]